I moved out to Silicon Valley in 2010
everyone warned me that there's a bubble
right now it's gonna burst in the next
six months just you know just be aware
and people kept saying that just
constantly always saying it six months
away six months away I don't really
think there's a bubble right now to be
quite honest we are at the edge so many
exciting opportunities across tech and
biotech we have a lot of real businesses
with real customers with real revenue if
you build your business to be nimble you
build your workforce to be ok will
change you build a diverse workforce
when that change happens you'll be able
to deal with this I think they need to
think about sustainable capitalism they
need to think about a model that can
exist for the long term
so the most transformative force that's
it's really coming down the pipeline I
think is artificial intelligence our
company focuses on CRISPR genome editing
and the ability to specifically change
DNA sequences inside of living cells you
people keep talking about games for VR
I'm just like no this is gonna change
the way we all work it's gonna change
our lives honestly any company that we
fund we're asking our founders to make a
commitment to diversity and inclusion
and to bake it in to their startups
I think the AI community is a great
example of a collection of folks who
have come together in a way to
proactively think about
self-organization and self-regulation in
part in reaction to questions coming
from the average consumer for open AI in
particular one thing that we've really
done is we've removed most of the
traditional constraints that exist on
businesses one research organizations so
that we can just focus on one thing
which is advancing these technologies in
the way that is best for the world it's
important to have diversity in your
workforce because honestly your
customers aren't all one segment of the
population
you don't have to come to Silicon Valley
to be successful magically is based in
Fort Lauderdale Florida which what tech
is there I think that there's really no
substitute for really spending a bunch
of time just trying to build things that
are useful that people use to build it
wrong a bunch of times and that's really
the only way to figure out how to build
it ready